let's say that i run some type of a
pension fund and i have one billion
dollars that i need to invest someplace
and i dig around a little bit and
there's this company a over here and it
needs to borrow a billion dollars and
it's willing it's willing to give 10
percent interest in exchange for
borrowing that billion dollars so if i
give these characters over here
my billion dollars if i lend it to them
if i lend them the billion dollars on an
annual basis they're going to give me 10
percent interest there's a problem here
though the ratings they the rating
agencies
the ones that in theory should be
independent they've only given the
company a a double b rating and this is
a pension fund i have to only invest in
the safest of safest of securities i
have to invest only in things that are
double a
and so here might enter a character like
aig
and obviously
things have changed since their heyday
but aig based on at least moody's
perspective
it has a double a rating
so aig could say hey look pension fund
why don't you lend them the money and
what we're going to do is enter into a
credit default swap and what that
essentially is is a form of insurance of
that 10 percent every year why don't you
give us one percent of that and in
financial lingo that's sometimes
referred to as 100 basis points and in
exchange for that in exchange for that
100 basis points a year you can view
this as the insurance premium
we are going to
ensure
we are going to ensure
that if for whatever reason company b or
sorry company a defaults on that debt
you can give us the debt you can give us
you can give us that that debt security
and we will just give you back your
billion dollars now from the pensions
point of view this sounds pretty good
they're now getting a net nine percent
of interest ten percent minus the one
percent
and they're essentially going getting
getting to lend to a double b company
but it's in effect like lending to a
double a because as long as aig is good
for the money then the pension comp the
pension fund is going to get their money
back one way or the other
now where this gets a little bit shady
is aig right here didn't have to do
anything what's what's interesting about
credit default swaps
credit default swap sometimes refer to
cds's is that even though they are
insurance for all purposes they are
insurance they are not regulated like
insurance so typically an insurance
company when they insure something they
have to set aside some money in case
that thing actually happens and they
have to work out the probabilities and
all that the credit default swaps were
not regulated in that way so aig could
do this without having to set aside any
type of money and they could do this
over and over and over and over again
kind of snowballing all of their
potential liabilities and so you can
imagine it's really good money while no
one is defaulting but all of a sudden
while people when people start
defaulting then all of a sudden aig is
going to be in trouble and all the
people who thought they had in effect
double a debt because aig was insuring
it might not